hear me okay great thanks very much um
do we have an echo or is that okay you
can hear me somebody watching
the talking on streaming in the room
okay okay thanks um
so we don't get a whoops shouldn't this
work
is this not advancing
advancing the slide
so just which ones are the top ones okay
thanks
um all right so we're going to we'll
have a brief commercial break so the
advertising
for an upcoming conference um so since
you're all at a mathematics uh
modern cryptography conference you
should all be interested in the upcoming
mathematics of cryptography conference
at uc irvine
which is going to take place very soon
august 31st through september 3rd and
the organizers some of whom
you may know some may actually be in
this room
and that in fact is approximately where
it's going to be and this is a
photograph
that was actually taken by participants
of a similar workshop a similar
conference two years ago
a conference called in fact lattices
with symmetry
and what we actually saw was a blue
whale which is the largest mammal on the
planet and we saw dolphins these were
uh dancing under the bow of our boat and
uh
some of you can vouch for the fact that
i think we have a few people here who
are actually on that boat and can vouch
for the fact
that we actually did see this from our
boat and we plan to have another
excursion our excursion we also expect
to be a boat out in the ocean looking
for whales and looking for dolphins so
i encourage anyone who's interested come
for the dolphins stay for the
mathematics
okay so let me first start with the
punch line we're going to be talking
about lattices with symmetry
so if you have large rank it's difficult
to decide whether your lattice has an
orthonormal basis another way of saying
that
is it's difficult to decide whether the
lattice is isomorphic to z to the n
but it's easier for lattices that have
additional structure so if you have
lattices with
enough symmetries we you can actually
solve this problem so that's what i
i think i said on the first slide
everything i'm going to be saying is
joint work with hendrick lundstra
and what we do is we give an algorithm
that decides whether a given lattice
with sufficiently many symmetries
has an orthonormal basis and if it does
then we give an algorithm for finding it
and this is i'm not only inspired by but
very much based on
an algorithm that goes back a number of
years that was due to
craig gentry and mike zidlow but what
i'd like to do is to tell you a story
which is um what our motive what our
original motivation was and how we ended
up
um coming up with this algorithm so
um it was about four or five years ago
so
just after the smart for catering work
came about hendrick lundstrom went to a
talk on it i think given by frafer
calderon
which was about the this paper that was
mentioned in the last talk and some
other talks on fully homomorphic
encryption with relatively small key and
text sizes and hendrick had some ideas
related to that
and he and i started discussing them and
that's what
eventually led to this work but after
some intermediate steps that i'd like to
briefly tell you about so you um saw a
little bit maybe in the last talk but
i'll briefly recall a version of
and everything i'm going to tell you is
going to be oversimplified
but a version of the schemes of smart
for catering and gentry
levy um so as we've been seeing in a
number of talks
let's let capital n be a power of two
and f of x is x to the n plus one
and we're going to take the number field
k which is q
square bracket x modulo f of x so that's
a cycloatomic field
generated by primitive two nth roots of
unity
a primitive two and root of unity and um
in order to set up the cryptosystem
we're going to take um
a polynomial v of x of degree n minus
one
with integer coefficients that are
random t bit
integers for a suitably chosen parameter
t
and we're going to take this matrix v
where the first row
is the coefficients of the polynomial
and then we're going to make this
sort of an anti-circulant matrix from
that so we get
an n by n matrix and the rows are just
the coefficients of
x to the i times v to the v of x mod
f of x where i is running from 0 to n
minus 1.
and the lattice that we consider the
lattice l is the lattice
in z to the n generated by the rows of v
and we're going to let little d be
either you can take it as the
determinant of the matrix or
equivalently the
determinant of the lattice and if d were
not is not
odd and square free you try again with a
new v of x
and you don't really need to know what's
going on here but as in the last talk
the bad basis the public basis
or the public matrix is going to be b
which you can just take to be the hermet
normal form of the matrix v
the fact that we chose little d to be
odd and square free
tells us that this matrix constructed in
this way that you don't have to know
is in fact the hermit normal form of v
so we have an n by n matrix v
which is coming from some randomly
chosen polynomial
and we take the hermit normal form that
gives us our
matrix b so our public key
is b our secret key is v so the rows of
v
are giving us our lattice l and those
rows are giving us a good basis
for the lattice and that's our secret
key and the rows of b
are giving us a different basis for the
lattice and that's our bad basis
and that's our public key so in the um
in some of these schemes you want to
encrypt a bit so suppose b
is your bit you choose a random noise
polynomial so that's u of x which
let's take the coefficients to be from
the set 0 plus or minus 1 where they
take the values 1 and minus 1 with equal
probability
so this is your noise polynomial and
you're going to take the bit and you're
going to add it to
twice the noise polynomial and then
you're going to take the coefficients of
that and that gives you a vector
so a vector in in r to the n and the
cipher text so this you can think of
as how you're incl encoding your plain
text so this is your plain text message
point in euclidean space and what the
cipher text is well there's you could
write down a formula for it but
basically what you do
is you take this plain text point and
you translate it
to the fundamental parallelopipet
corresponding to the public
bad basis for your lattice so let me
give you i'll give you a picture of that
in a slide very soon but let me just
point out so decryption you take your
cipher text
and you translate it back which means
mean going to mean you
translate it to the fundamental
parallelopipet corresponding
to your secret key which is your good
basis for the lattice so let me draw a
picture so you do that you get
your plain text point you look at the
first coordinate you take it mod 2
and that's going to give you your bit so
just to give you a picture
so here since i could only draw things
in two dimensions we have a
two-dimensional lattice so the black
points are your lattice
you can let's um take as generators our
bad generators are going to be
this point and this point so you get a
parallelogram
that they generate that they span and
we're going to translate that so that
it's centered at the origin
just for for some just to make things
nice so this is the
fundamental region translated to the
origin centered about the origin
this green point is going to be your
plain text point
so that was that that a that i had on an
earlier slide
and so if you want to find the
ciphertext what you do is you move it
into the fundamental region to the
fundamental parallelogram
so in other words you find a lattice
point where you can add that lattice
point
to the site to the plain text point in
order to put you into the fundamental
region so there's a unique way to do
that there's a unique lattice point that
you can add
there's a unique point in the
fundamental region that you can
translate it to
so that red point is the ciphertext
point and if you want to go back what
you do
is you take that red point your cipher
text and you translate it into the
fundamental parallelogram associated
with the good basis
and the good basis is hopefully more
orthogonal and
hopefully this works and you can
translate it back
um so what they're
so their secret bases remember the
consists of the rows
of a matrix where the first row is
chosen basically at random
um the more randomly it's chosen the
higher the security
but what hendrick noticed and what he
pointed out to them was that the less
likely that one can actually decrypt
so decryption will fail if your
plaintext point does not lie in the
fundamental parallel pipe but
corresponding to the
to the good matrix so he pointed out
that actually decryption had a problem
in the original smart for catering
scheme um and that was an issue and
that's what actually led to our working
together
on this
so one way to try to deal with that so
we're going to try to make decryption
more feasible
rather than taking the coefficients of
your polynomial v
to be random t bit integers um
so in converse i guess um free for
catering told hendrick and and
conversations between craig and myself
um they both suggested taking um
the constant term v zero to be
roughly two to the t and taking the
remaining v is very small compared to
two to the t so that
these coefficients this coefficient
vector looks roughly like this
and then the resulting basis is then
orthogonal enough to
allow efficient decryption but then the
question is is this secures is this
impinged on the security
um so hendrick and i started analyzing
that and so we
analyzed it from the following point of
view which is that so you take
let v be take your polynomial v
evaluated at primitive to nth root of
unity
well remember that the only there's this
dominant
constant term and everything else is
negligible so it's approximately the
same as the constant term v
zero our lattice was defined to be
well so you can think of it as the
principal ideal generated
by this this um element v
um sitting inside remember our number
field k our sickle atomic field
um take k tensor the real numbers so
that's complex numbers to the n over 2.
view that as being r to the n so this is
euclidean space we have a lattice now
l embedded in euclidean space r to the n
and our d which was the determinant of
the lattice has the property that d to
the 1 over n
is approximately the absolute value of
this constant term
so now if we look in so in k tensor r
or ambient space we can look at well one
is
just an element of our field one tensor
d to the one over n
view that as an element of our r to the
n
what we're saying here is that this
element this alpha
is very close to v and v is a lattice
point
so an alpha is basically public d is
public
n is public so this is this is a public
public information
um and if you want to recover the secret
v what you can do is try to find the
closest lattice vector
to alpha and that's going to be v so
and we um kendrick noticed that a v one
or we notice i guess that
that v one up to v n minus one are too
small then the closest lattice vector
um to alpha is much closer than the next
closest lattice vector
and what we know from lll is that then
the lll algorithm will find it
so that was an issue in terms of of
using that
that modification in terms of the
security
um so at that point we started modifying
the
smart for catering scheme um using for
the secret key a lattice basis that was
that we called nearly orthogonal so it
was orthogonal enough to make decryption
feasible
while we tried to make it random enough
to still be secure
and we had this very nice system that
used some nice mathematics and it uses a
renormalization of gauss's measure
and it had all sorts of nice features
except that at some point i gave a talk
about it
and um daniella after the talk um
told me well he was worried that it
imposed that what we had done imposed
too much structure
and he suggested that we go back to the
gentry zidlo paper and have a look at an
algorithm in that paper
to see if it gives an attack on what we
were proposing
and that turned out to be an excellent
idea and led to much more interesting
things than what we had been doing
before that
um so thank you for that um so what's
the paper of gentry and zidlow that he
sent us back to
um so it was called cryptanalysis of the
revised and true signature scheme
it was in eurocrypt 2002.
and um so i started looking through the
paper and i showed it to hendrick and
said hendrick look at this paper there's
some interesting things here and he said
oh this is just
cryptography and it's uh it was hard to
read paper they said no hendrick this is
okay look at this
and at some point he looked and he said
hey wait a second there are things in
here about lattices that i don't know
and that hendrick didn't know how to
prove and there were some genuinely new
ideas that he found very impressive so
when when hendrick lenstra
sees something new about lattices that's
that's
time i think to stop and take note so
here's a picture that was around taken
by me around the time
that gendry and zidlow came up with
their algorithm this was asia crypt
2001 on the gold coast of australia so i
think they were not toasting
the this was just the banquet at asia
crypt they were not toasting the
algorithm but i think that's when they
were doing the work
who are they with how many people
recognize so i'm in the missing seat
because i was taking the picture
yeah craig is there
mike is here mike zidler is here this is
fung this is steven galbraith
and this is i guess is ben lin who did
hierarchical identity-based encryption
stuff like that
what's that what um that it's an asia
[ __ ] banquet and everyone was getting
drunk and it was fun and it was nice
being in australia especially after
september 11th which was right before
that
we were all finally away from uh we were
having fun we were having a good time
and they were doing the gentry zidler
algorithm although the rest of us
probably didn't know that
okay so what is the gentry sidle
algorithm so i'm actually only looking
at the part of the algorithm in i think
section maybe seven of their
paper so they have an algorithm and i'm
only looking at a certain part of it
and the part that we care that pendrick
and i care about was
and the part i care about for this talk
was what they do is they're looking at
the ring
z score bracket x mod x to the n minus
one so that's something we've been
seeing a bit here um and what they have
is a principal ideal in that ring and
the input to the algorithm is a z basis
for the ideal
and v v bar where v
is promised to be a generator for that
ideal
and what the algorithm does is it
recovers the generator
or generator v for the principle ideal
so you have a promise that ideal is
principle
you're given a z basis for it you're
given vv bar and you want to output v
so here n is an odd prime and what do i
mean by
by v bar well so v is this polynomial
v bar is what's called its reversal so
you keep the constant term the same
and you reverse the other coefficients
and it's called bar
because if you view this as being
sitting inside a product of sickle
atomic fields it really is just complex
conjugation in that case um
so you want to think maybe a vv bar as
the crucial hint that is giving you
enough structure
or enough symmetry in order to recover v
is v d bar the gram matrix
of the right corresponds to the gram
matrix of the
basis that's right um so
very very roughly and again i'm vastly
oversimplifying um
their method was to very briefly
choose auxiliary very large primes p and
p
prime that have the property that the
gcd the greatest common divisor of p
minus 1 and p
prime minus 1 is 2n so remember we were
looking at z-score
x minus x to the n minus 1. it's the
same n
then they use certain somewhat
mysterious looking polynomial chains and
the ll algorithm
to compute v to the p minus 1 and v to
the p
prime minus 1 modulo other auxiliary
primes without actually knowing v yet
and then they use the euclidean
algorithm and the statement that they
know about the gcds
in order to take these two things modulo
certain things and compute v
to the 2n and from that they were able
to extract a 2 nth root
to recover v so roughly that's what they
were doing
um
i will say a little bit more about step
two in a later slide um
so this is the rough algorithm i didn't
understand anything
right okay so then there's the fact that
that
um yeah so there's the question of what
is
what is going on here um and that was
that was that was partly our question is
what is going on here because the
genders of the paper in fact you can
follow the algorithm
and see what it does but the question of
why they did this and why it works
was kind of our question it was
something of a mystery and i think to
most people reading that paper it was
something of a mystery
and so part of what we consider to be
our accomplishment
is to say okay here's the actual
mathematics
underlying these ideas if you translate
this
into mathematics then it starts making
sense at least to mathematicians
um and so that's part of what i want to
communicate is that there were things
that
people did not understand these
polynomial chains in particular you know
what exactly was going on you can follow
it line by line and check that things
worked but why
you know what was really happening
wasn't so clear and it's not necessarily
useful to
actually go into those details so i
think i and i don't have time um
okay so in terms of what we did that was
different so we did a lot of things that
were the same but
converting things to a mathematical
formulation
um one thing that we did that allowed us
to go further and do some things a bit
better
were they were using ideal lattices
and idea lattices are lattices and
they're also ideals
in rings and so they were and they were
using the
structure as an ideal and what we said
was you don't need to actually use that
just use the module structure you can
throw away
so what's an ideal an ideal is a module
along with an embedding of the module
into the ring
and we said throw away the embedding
into the ring what's the advantage of
doing that well when you multiply ideals
together you can write things with
respect to any z
basis but the coefficients with respect
to that basis are going to grow very
quickly you have coefficient blow up
because of the way the ideals are
embedded in the ring what we do instead
is we forget
about that embedding into the ring we're
tensoring abstract modules
and we can avoid keeping track of these
embeddings and we can avoid the large
coefficients and avoid
um some of the coefficient blow up in
that way so that was one thing
um so that by saying forget that these
are ideals just use that they're modules
we were able to gain something from that
i'm going back to these polynomial
chains and that's step two that you
asked about
um so these are the polynomial chains so
there are these um and i think here
maybe the v
that you started with was v zero and
they slowly build up these polynomial
chains and they're getting more and more
information until they get enough
information
that they can compute v to the p minus
one and so on
using the hint yeah they start with vv
bar they use the hint they compute these
polynomial chains
sort of at the same there's two chains
that they're computing
step by step at the same time one
feeding to the other i think if i'm
remembering correctly and it's
complicated and it's not
that's never ever quite clear to people
why that worked
what we're doing instead is something
that at least mathematically
seems more natural which is so here l is
your ideal lattice
and we take l and we take l tensor with
itself so l tensor l
this l uh tensor3 means l tensor l
tensor l and so on
and we also take something that i'll
maybe define later l to the zero and
then we have an l bar which you want to
think of as an
inverse lattice
and an elbar tensor with itself and so
on we get this graded tensor algebra so
here we have a grading we have the
zeroth piece the first piece second
third
and minus one minus 2 and so on and we
claim that if you do
all your arithmetic inside that you can
do a nice
mathematically nice algorithm that
accomplishes what gentry and zillow are
trying to accomplish and also allows you
to maybe do some other things
so where they were using these auxiliary
large primes p and p
prime we end up using some auxiliary
large prime powers and what that gains
us
is we can then apply a certain analytic
number three result that i'll tell you
about in a couple of minutes i should
also say that i was told
um that i'm allowed to do more than half
an hour because there were people who
were saying you can't possibly tell us
anything in half an hour so
um i'm assuming i should warn you if you
need to leave you
you can leave in the middle of the talk
so i'll tell you a little bit later
about how
about the analytic number theory result
i'll just state it um
what that allows us to do is they had a
heuristic
run time that was based on some
heuristic assumptions and what we end up
with is a
both a more efficient algorithm and
something that's provably deterministic
polynomial time
okay um so we said so we saw lattices
earlier in this workshop and people said
okay a lattice is something contained in
r to the n now for us
a lattice is defined differently so it's
not necessarily something contained in r
to the n
for us a lattice is going to be a
finitely generated a billion group
along with an inner product so by inner
product i mean
a map from l cross l to the integers
where l is your finally generated value
and group l is your lattice
that is bilinear symmetric and positive
definite and i'm going to take that as a
definition of the lattice
so the standard lattice is going to be
just z to the n with the inner product
just being the usual dot product so
that's something very familiar
and having an orthonormal basis is the
same as being isomorphic
to the standard lattice of the same rank
so remember i said at the beginning that
what we're doing is
if under certain additional extra
structure
we answer the question we decide whether
something has a lattice has an
orthonormal basis
and if so we find it um so i said
isomorphic to the standard lattice what
do i mean by isomorphic an isomorphism
of lattices
is just a group isomorphism so if l and
m are your lattices it's a group
isomorphism say from l to m
that respects the lattice structures so
when i say respect the lattice
structures
i just mean that it respects the inner
products on the two lettuces and an
automorphism is an isomorphism from the
lattice onto itself
okay so what we then introduced were
what we call g
lattices and these are the lattices with
symmetry so when i say lattices with
symmetry i'm going to mean g
lattice so how do we want to define a g
lattice we're going to take we're going
to fix throughout the rest of the talk a
finite abelian group g
with an element of order two and let's
call that distinguished element u
um a g lattice is going to be a lattice
with a g action
where u is acting like minus one so
another way to say a g
action with u acting like minus one is
that we have a lattice a long a lattice
let's say l
along with a group homomorphism from g
to the set of automorphisms of l
where the element u in the group goes to
the
automorphism minus one so it takes
anything of the lattice and sends it to
the
additive inverse if i have
two g lattices l and m i'm going to say
that they are g
isomorphic if you have an isomorphism
between them as lattices
that not only respects the lattice
structure but also respects the g
action so that means if you take an x
over here
if you take sigma of x where sigma is in
the group
then the image of sigma of x is sigma of
the image of x
that's what this says so just a natural
respecting of the g action so that's
what we mean by a g isomorphism
and these are our lattices with symmetry
okay so let's take an example an example
is what i'm going to be calling the
standard g
lattice and i might occasionally call it
the modified group ring
so what is that and i'll also give some
more concrete examples of this
um you know in a second um so the a
standard thing
in mathematics is the group ring so g is
my group um z-score brackets g just
means take the formal sums
where the sigmas are running over the
elements of the group and the
coefficients are integers
so that's what this group ring is so
this is known as the group ring
and what we're going to do is so um in
that i have
u plus one where one i just mean the
identity element in the group
so i'm gonna mod out by the ideal
generated by u plus one in other words
take
this group ring and we're gonna identify
you with minus one remember we said u is
acting like minus 1 anyway
so that's what we want to do so this is
our
modified group ring and this is going to
be a standard g lattice so why is it a g
lattice well the j action is clear you
just take anything in here
you can multiply by an element of the
group you still get something in here
so the g action is clear the lattice
structure is something we're going to
have to impose
something we're going to have to define
so that just means we want to define an
inner product
i'm going to define the inner product as
follows so it's going to be t
of something where t takes something in
the group ring
and it sends it to the coefficient of
the identity element minus the
coefficient
of u so that's what t does and it's to
be t of x
y bar where bar means whenever you see
an element of the group you replace it
by
its inverse in the group and it turns
out
that this um gives you this turns this
ring into a g lattice using the
definition of the other slot
so you can all check this if you if you
wanted to it's all just
straightforward um verification so this
is what we'll call the standard g
lattice and in maybe the next slide i'll
give you some examples
but let me point out that first of all
it is a
g lattice of rank n where um
2n is the order of the group so remember
we have a group with an element of order
2 so we know that group has to have even
order
call that order 2n and let's define n
that defines a number n
an integer n um this then turns out to
be a g lattice of rank n
as lattice is it's just the standard
lattice z to the n but it has this
additional
um g action
and it turns out that as a ring it's an
integral domain
if and only if g is cyclic and n is a
power of two so we're seeing these two
power things coming up again
as you've been seeing in cryptography
and there are reasons maybe for that
okay so here are the examples
so if i take particular groups g i can
see what this standard g lattice is in
those examples
and then you can see that we're
recovering some of the rings that we're
interested in
for cryptography okay so let's start by
g
being so we have this u is an element of
order two take the sub group generated
by u
um take the direct sum the rec product
of that with a cyclic group of order n
then it turns out that this standard g
lattice this modified group ring
is just the group ring where the group
is now the cyclic group of order n
and that you tell you take a generator
of here and map it to x and you get an
isomorphism to z-score bracket x modulo
x to the n minus 1.
so in that case it's just z-score again
x minus x-and minus one these
isomorphisms are both isomorphisms both
as rings
and as lattices um
in particular if g is cyclic then this
uh
standard g lattice is z-score bracket x
mod x to the n
plus one and if g is cyclic of order two
to the n then we just recover the ring
of integers in the cycloatomic field
generated by a primitive two to the
earth root of unity
so here we're recovering some of the
cycloatomic rings that we're interested
in for cryptography
and also recovering the situation
considered by gentry and zidler
okay so what's our main algorithm now i
can give you an explicit
correct statement of what we prove or
what our main theorem is
what we do is give a deterministic
polynomial time algorithm
that decides whether a g lattice is g
isomorphic to the standard g
lattice and if it is it exhibits such an
isomorphism
so why does that answer the question
that i stated in
one of my earliest slides which was
about
finding an orthonormal basis well if i
take this standard g
lattice um z brackets g
um the way you can get so we said that
was a rank n
lattice if you take half the group
elements namely you take a set of coset
representatives for g
modulo the subgroup generated by u that
gives you n
elements those will give you an
orthonormal basis
so this always has an orthonormal basis
and it's and you get it from half the
group elements
and so it follows from this that this
algorithm decides whether a g
lattice has an orthonormal basis and it
finds one if it does
so it takes a lattice with symmetry and
it determines whether it has an
orthonormal basis and if it does it
finds one
okay so if one question is how do we
recover the gentry zidlo algorithm from
from this algorithm what does it have to
do with gentry zidla so let me explain
that next i think i can do that on two
slides
i usually do it on one but i decided to
to be nice and do it in two slides
okay suppose that i is an ideal in z
brackets g
or if you prefer you can be more general
and take it to be a fractional ideal
and you can take w either to be in your
your group rings
in your modified group ring z brackets g
or more generally you can take the
coefficients to be rational numbers if
you like you can take it
to be in here so if i is your ideal
suppose that i i bar is contained in z
brackets g times w and suppose that w
is totally positive so what do i mean by
totally positive
i mean that for every ring homomorphism
into the complex numbers w actually gets
mapped to a positive real number so it's
natural definition of what it means to
be totally positive for every embedding
into the complex numbers
w actually goes to a positive real
number so it's a totally positive
element
um if you're in that setting then it
turns out that i is a g
lattice well the g action is clear
because it's an ideal in
in z brackets g or q brackets g so it's
just the g
action is just multiplication by
elements of the group the lattice
structure you have to be a bit more
careful with
the lattice structure we're going to
define in this way we remember t was
what we had before we had t of x y bar
was defining our inner product on z
brackets g
on this ideal and i deal with this
property
what we want to do is to find the
lattice structure by t of x y bar
over w and it turns out that would make
this into a g lattice
and it will be a useful g lattice in
terms of recovering the gentry zidler
algorithm and i'll show you that on the
next slide
so we're going to denote that g lattice
as l i come in w so the set is just i
but the structure the lattice structure
is given by this complicated by this
inner product
for example if you just want a
particular example take your ideal i
to be z brackets g take w to be
one and then this is just you're just
recovering the standard
lattice so that's an example of this
okay so how do we recover the gentry
zebra algorithm so remember what did the
gentry
zooto algorithm do it started with this
rings these two bracket
x y x v n minus one where n was an odd
prime
and you're inputting um a z basis for an
ideal that you're promised is principle
and you're given v b bar and you want to
recover v
so what do we do so we want to apply our
algorithm to solve this problem
we let g be a cyclic group of order 2n
where n
is is this n so then we said an earlier
slide the standard
g lattice is then z score brackets x
minus x to the n minus one which is the
ring that we
care about in the gentry ziploc problem
our algorithm then produces um
so what does it do it checks whether
there's a
g isomorphism from this lattice between
this lattice
and the standard g lattice that's what
our algorithm is doing and in this case
because we have this principle ideal
um it will produce your g isomorphism so
it's producing a g
isomorphism from this lattice to this
one this being just the ideal i
and it does it in polynomial time
if we take the image of one under this
map what we recover
is a generator v of the ideal
so that's how you recover the gentry
zillow algorithm from
the algorithm that i stated
from the theorem that i stated saying
that there exists an algorithm that does
a certain thing
um so briefly in terms of what we do a
little bit differently
so i said that gentry and zidlow look at
auxiliary primes p
and p prime large primes with this
property what we replace that with is we
let k be the exponent of the group g
so the exponent is the smallest positive
integer k
such that sigma to the k equals one for
every sigma in the group
so it divides the order of the group and
it has the same prime factors as the
order of the group
and we let k of m for any inner positive
positive integer
m with the exponent of well take um
z brackets g mod out by the ideal
generated by m and take the unit group
of that
and what we do is we replace their large
primes by auxiliary prime powers l and m
such that the gcd of these two exponents
k of l and k of
m is equal to k the exponent of g so
it's that looks very much the same
as what they did except that for some
reason we're doing things a little bit
differently and the reason
is that their finding of those primes
those large primes p and p
prime required a heuristic argument and
we can find our prime powers
with a provably deterministic polynomial
time algorithm
by using a certain theorem and analytic
number theory which maybe i won't
i'll just skip over and if and reference
the paper if anybody wants to see it
but this is what allows us to give us
something
provably deterministic when theirs was
not
so there's some nice number theory
involved there and also they had
certain requirements that certain that
the things they were dealing with not be
zero divisors
modular various primes and we have no
such condition in our case
another thing that we introduced that
turns out to be important is the concept
of being invertible so we're dealing
with invertible g
lattices invertible means it has an
inverse so here the inverse
what you want to do is in the realm of g
lattices you want to think of your
identity element as being the standard g
lattice so this is your identity element
your operation is you're tensoring
your g lattices where you're tensoring
over this uh
this this lattice um so being invertible
means it has an inverse so l being
invertible
is going to mean that l is a unimodular
lattice and there's a z brackets g
module m such that l tensor m tensoring
over
over this is isomorphic to z brackets g
as z brackets g modules so you want to
think of m as the inverse of l
so l times m is the identity element so
m is the inverse of l that's the way
this should be thought about um so in
particular the standard g lattice is
invertible by just taking
m to be the standard g lattice it's its
own inverse it's the identity element
it's invertible um
okay so the major one of the major steps
of our proof is to show that a g lattice
so we care whether it's g
isomorphic to the standard g lattice
turns out it's gsomorphic to the
standard g
lattice if and only if it's invertible
and has a vector of length one
and in fact if you have if you look at
the set of g isomorphisms that we're
interested in so g
isomorphisms from the standard g lattice
to the one you care about
if l is invertible then
if you take such an isomorphism you can
look at f of one it's going to be a
vector here
since one has length one over here this
image has length one over here so you're
mapping to the set of vectors of length
one
and this map that takes your isomorphism
f and sends it to f of one this is going
to be a bijection
so the set of g isomorphisms is in
bijection with the vectors of length one
if you start with an invertible g
lattice and if you have a vector of
length one
um then the set of vectors of length one
is just um apply sigma
to your given vector so you end up with
exactly well so the
vectors of length one you either have
none of them or you have two n of them
and if you want to determine whether or
not you have such a g isomorphism
well what you want to do according to
this theorem is you want to first check
and see if it's invertible
and if it's invertible you want to find
a vector of length one
and if you can find a vector of length
one then you know how to find your g
isomorphism you just go back via this
bijection
okay so let me just very very briefly
sketch the algorithm i'm almost done
so first step check whether so we want
we said there is a g isomorphism if and
only if
the lattice is invertible and has a
vector of length one so you first
checked and see if it's invertible we
have an algorithm for doing that
you then use this analytic number theory
result to give a polynomial time
algorithm to produce
large prime powers in fact greater than
2 to the n over 2
such that this gcd is k
you then compute an element of the
lattice that generates
capital l modulo little m times
little l times m as a module over this
for that we actually
use some commutative algebra to produce
a general algorithm that decides if a
finite module over a finite commutative
ring is cyclic
and if it is it produces a generator and
then we apply that here
what's the complexity uh well again it's
polynomial i mean these are all
polynomial time
algorithms but i guess i'd have to see
would them the problem of finding a
generator in a
in an ideal lactase
um well here i'm looking at finite so
these are finite
molecules over finite rings and that's
crucial
and how does the complexity depends on
the size of these
uh communities we would have to
talk let's talk about that offline i
think i'm i'm running out of time um but
yeah we have a paper that
uh that says that it's online and that
we can have a look at
that um okay so we have this generator
for this uh
for this finite um module
um we then use that so this this this
thing this generator
what we do is we tensor it with itself k
of m times
we then look at this coset so we're
looking at at this thing modulo m
and so we get a coset there this namely
this this element of that which is this
coset
and it turns out this has these have
been chosen large enough that you can
actually use lll to solve a closest
vector problem in this coset
and what that gives you is a vector of
length one
in here if one exists so it tells you
whether or not
you have one and if it does it actually
produces one
once you have this vector of length one
in here then you want to use this that
this gcd is k to bring this down
bring this k of m down to k so k of them
as large you want to bring it down to k
which is small and manageable
so you do that um the next step find a
vector of length one and
l tensor with itself k times you use the
euclidean algorithm to get from k of m
to k
and you again use lll to solve a closest
vector problem in a certain coset that
i'm not don't have time to define for
you
where rather than looking at the things
modulo m you're now looking at things
modular little l
then you want to basically extract a kth
root of that vector
so you want to find a vector of length 1
in l if one exists
so this is analogous to finding the i
guess the 2 nth root that gentry and
zidler were doing
and what we use there is quite a lot of
commutative algebra
to give an algorithm that finds
generators for the roots of uterine of
any order
and we use this to extract a k root
of our short vector that we got in the
previous step once you have a vector of
length one
then the desired isomorphism is you take
anything in here and you multiply it by
that vector of length 1 and that gives
it your isomorphism
and i should also add that in addition
we don't just
determine an algorithm to decide whether
something is isomorphic to the standard
g
lattice we use that then to then um it's
just an easy step from that to
get an algorithm to decide whether two
invertible g lattices are g
isomorphic and if so it computes such an
isomorphism such a g
isomorphism
so one thing i should add is that these
algorithms are not known to weaken the
security of ring lwe
so we don't we're not claiming that we
can break that but we are saying that if
you have
structure and as chris said in the
previous talk if you have structure it's
probably exploitable
exploitable structures abound
so maybe i'll just add some work in
progress we have some other applications
of some
so we ended up with this very nice
commuter of algebra
that we used as subroutines in our
algorithm
and these commuter algebra results
actually have other applications
including to pointing out settings where
you wouldn't want to
base something on the discrete log
problem being hard because it turns out
it's easy so no settings
in which anybody's actually using them
at the moment but settings where people
might want to be careful in the future
if they're thinking about using them
and we also have generalizations that
encounter that will encompass more
lattices
that are potentially a cryptographic
interest including um
things associated with rings of integers
and arbitrary cm fields or totally real
fields
um and their products so i think uh
and so these are some of the references
so the early stuff that i mentioned is
in a
preprint that isn't public and may never
be public but the other
things are all either i guess everything
else is public except for the one
that's in preparation so maybe i will
give thanks to the sponsors and remind
you of the ad and take any questions
mathematics
as far as i know the original gentry
sitlow algorithm was never actually
implemented
uh have you gone so far as to implement
this
uh we have not um and i don't know
if other people have i think yeah i
don't know
also there are a lot of optimizations
that we know can be done to this that we
haven't done but that we're hoping other
people will if anybody wants to
implement it